hey everyone thank you for joining us
for another middle-ground episode be
sure to stick around after the episode
because we're going to talk about how we
make middle ground and also what we've
learned from them enjoy you know a lot
of conversations so far nobody has
brought up the rights of the fetus
person doesn't she have the right but
the choice to live but with that being
said that's that's a cluster of cells
that could not a lot of the time exist
outside of a woman's world hi my name is
Jolene I am a college student and I'm
pro-life hello everyone my name is Tim
Murray and I'm pro-life and I talk about
these issues on my radio show trending
with timrie I'm Jason I'm a youtuber
called pastor Jason answers so yes I'm a
Christian pastor my name is Liz I work
in tech and I am pro-choice my name is
Kimberly I am a college student and I am
pro-choice hey guys I'm Natalie I'm a
poet teaching artist and mental health
advocate and I am pro-choice
I know someone who's had an abortion
I guess I'll go first I have had to
myself the first one I was not
emotionally stable
I was not financially stable I was about
to get evicted from where I was living
and my family wouldn't you know the the
list goes on and on I was on drugs it
wasn't something that I would be able to
do nor I wanted to do and recently I had
a miscarriage in which because it was
incomplete I had to go in for a DNC
which is instant abortion procedure and
at this point in my life I want to have
kids and so you know that experience as
well was something that was equally as
difficult for me as the first one that I
had to go through voluntarily I'm so
sorry I went to experience church
supports WP CC which is an organization
that helps women during pregnancy after
pregnancy and post abortion counseling
more than the people that I've met there
my mom almost had an abortion because of
me she doesn't come me the whole story
because she doesn't like talk about it
but her life was in danger and everybody
was saying just abort the baby which is
totally legitimate if the woman's life
is in danger I believe but I'm actually
glad that uh she didn't abort me but had
the baby anyway I was 18 when I got my
first abortion and at that time I was
living with my grandmother
they were very conservative raised as
Catholic Christians they would probably
kick me out of the house if they were to
find out was pregnant I was still you
know fresh out of high school did not
have you know the monetary needs to
raise a child and no place to live so
yeah I have had both friends and
extended family members who have had
abortions and I'm sure the two of you
can speak to this it's a decision that
you carry with you the rest of your life
and I have seen people two years later
and I've seen people thirty years later
still struggling with the aftermath of
abortion and that's why I think us women
deserve so much more than abortion
I know several people who have been like
on the line like wanting to but I don't
know anyone who actually went through
with the process I have two little
brothers and when my mom was pregnant
with the youngest one he was not planned
and he was I mean I guess you could say
at that time he was an unwanted child
throughout her pregnancy she just was
thinking of how much of burden this
could be if my mom did not believe that
life begins at conception then she
probably would have gotten an abortion
but my baby brother well now he's older
he has impacted every single one of our
lives in such a positive way that I just
could not imagine him not being on this
planet and it really made me think that
when life is born like life is beautiful
and life is so much more beautiful than
there not being any life at all
I think that's sometimes true there's so
many other factors people who don't have
all of those things right who don't have
a family who don't maybe have a partner
who don't have stable housing is that
going to be the right circumstance for
that child is that gonna be more
damaging thinking about the quality of
the life that you can provide because
you are the caretaker of that being and
if you are not in a position to do that
that is the same as child abuse to me
and as sad as that is because you know
that's something we can't ignore I still
believe that that is a life and it is
just as valuable as someone who may be
growing up in a rich family and like
have everything and have all these
resources I believe both those lives are
equally valuable see I was just going to
say under what you're seeing it sounds
like quality of life is what determines
whether or not someone should live it
and in that case it's the poor people
who are preyed upon to have abortions
and it's support people who then spend
years struggling with post-abortion
syndrome as well and so what with
cutting off access to abortion what what
solution is that going to provide to
those low-income individuals people who
may not be able to have access to health
care there are crisis pregnancy centers
across the nation waiting with the
financial means to help women who are
facing crisis pregnancy the reality is
is when people choose to have their
children and they ask for help let's say
family cuts them off there are other
people willing to give help if we ask
have you had to receive
kind of benefits before no but I've
worked with hundreds upon hundreds of
women who have so based on my own
experience you know I'm someone who
previously granted I don't have children
but I would had previously had to be on
food stamps I previously have received
unemployment benefits pretty much
anything that you can name there was a
point in my life where I had to be able
to get that kind of assistance and it's
not as much money as you think and a lot
of these individuals are still
struggling to be able to provide for not
only their baby but themselves and I
think it's really unfair to put a woman
and you know this this now baby in that
situation against their own you know
against their own will men should not be
a part of the conversation it's not a
part of a man's body it's not a life
that they are personally bringing into
the world and I don't think that they
should be the end-all be-all to make
that choice well I'm the only guy here
and sometimes even before I speak a word
I feel judged that you have no say
because it's not your body but I have
two beautiful kids what if my wife
didn't want kids what if she had an
abortion without my say without my
advice doesn't disaffected a lot I
actually think everyone has to be a part
of every conversation now I don't think
men should be the dominant voice in the
conversation at all but I do think that
everybody has to work together to create
solutions to really large issues and so
yeah I think men absolutely have to be a
part of it but not the dominant voice
the realities it takes two to tango
right I think we can all agree on that
and the chromosomes come from both the
mother and the father that baby was a
part of the father as well I mean I I
guess I didn't necessarily want to say
that men absolutely shouldn't be a part
of the conversation where I see it is a
lot of the individuals who are trying to
make these laws right now are men well I
think that there still needs to be a
conversation between a couple I don't
think that it's fair for anybody other
than the woman having to go through this
make that final decision in what she
wants to do with her body how's a guy I
feel like my my statements are more
opinions or suggestions that it doesn't
really matter
thank you for your input but we really
need to make the decision based on what
the woman feels and I feel like I'm more
of a second-rate citizen compared to the
woman who has to make the real decision
yeah I mean I find that that's like the
one place men feel that way versus women
there's very many instances in our lives
where we don't get the first say and we
don't get the last say either we're
asking people permission to do things
with ourselves and I think for me that's
what's really problematic when it wasn't
legal people still got abortions and
they just died in alleys and so is that
what we're okay with as a society
because people don't have access and
don't have choices I'm not okay with
that
I feel as if my rights are in danger
some of these laws are allowing for
non-medical physicians to perform
abortions and operate without a medical
license so my right to good quality
health care is being diminished but also
my right as you know one day wanting to
be a parent parental notification those
laws are being swept away and so parents
who love their children more than the
facility workers or at least should
write they should be able to talk to
their child before they make such a
serious decision and the parents rights
are going away at the end of the day
that's not their choice to make that's
not their body and so I I get I guess I
just I get where you're coming from from
like an emotional standpoint but I
believe that an abortion is a medical
procedure and I don't think that anybody
else should really be involved other
than the person that's having it for me
I want women to have the right to make a
choice and there are states that are
saying we will make the choice for you
and that's problematic to me on an
equitable level attaching jail time and
all these things for women I don't see
the same thing happening for men it's
not the women who would be going to jail
it's people who are providing abortion
is that that would be facing criminal
charges so I understand the fear and I
think there's a lot of could we agree
there's a lot of media hype that's
creating a lack of communication and the
lack of clarity in a lot of areas and I
as a pro-lifer do not believe that any
woman seeking abortion should face
criminal charges this is me chill well
as an American I highly value my rights
and freedom to do what I want with my
body and things like that
these days I've been reconsidering my
views on gun control because you know
you know there's mass shootings and
innocent people are dying we have to do
something about that and and if I have
to step back and give up some rights to
own certain guns I'll consider it
because innocent people are dying and I
see it as the same thing with abortion
and in all our conversation so far
nobody has brought up the rights of the
fetus person doesn't she have the right
but the choice today
but with that being said that's that's a
cluster of cells that could not a lot of
the time exist outside of a woman's womb
III guess I'm just gonna have to agree
to disagree with you on that in an ideal
world totally if there were resources
and access and support like we wish
there were I'd be like totally nobody
should have abortions because we have a
society that supports people but we
actually don't live in a society where
that's true for everyone and so that's
the issue that's try right if you don't
draw the line at conception then where's
the line and when I hear people say oh
like you don't have the right to choose
what to do with my body because it's my
body I feel like I do because if you
were to have a pet animal and it was in
your backyard and you beat that thing to
death I feel like we all have moral
judgment and we I would stand up for
that buts not my animal and it's not my
backyard it's not my house I still
believe in my moral compass that I
should have the right to speak up about
it because I genuinely believe that that
is wrong abortion is killing human life
and so that is why I feel that I have
the right to say something about it
the responsibility of pregnancy
prevention is currently equal between
men and women
other than in cases of rape or incest
I believe that pregnancy prevention is
equal because we enter into sexual
intimacy both willingly yeah I agree
with that
it takes two people that make those
choices whether it's abstinence whether
it's using contraceptives consent is
what I think we're private prevention
starts okay I'll admit it it is easier
for us I mean even if there is a birth
control pill culturally today we're not
taking that we're not gonna snip and you
know it it's easier sorry no I agree
they always push it towards women if you
don't want to get pregnant yes there are
condoms out there for men to prevent
pregnancy however it's not nobody wears
yeah that's true
and they've also tried to come up with
you know various different birth control
methods for men no no and it's the
overwhelming response there's so many
side effects there's the possibility of
this and that and you know I've had a
friend that had a stroke because of her
birth control you know and I think that
it's really unfair that that
responsibility is solely being placed on
women well and also if it's gonna be
solely on me to prevent then it is
solely on me to make a choice thereafter
yeah I agree with what you guys are
saying but these conversations need to
be said before any action is done for
both people to understand that they are
both responsible for this I agree with
you and one of the things that I always
think about in the conversation of
abortion is education right any
education around our bodies or just
consent right or just rape all of these
things are not conversations that are
widely happening I think about my own
experience of sex Edie in high school
was taught by the gym teacher who was
also teaching us driver's training right
anything there and so I think about what
was the quality of the educational
experience I got and typically
my partnerships I am the first person
that my partner has encountered that is
willing and able to have a conversation
about sex about birth control about all
of these things so it's interesting that
we're like we should be having these
conversations but people don't have the
emotional intelligence to be having
these conversations or the emotional
immaturity which is unfortunate but it's
the reality right and so it does leave
the onus on the person who is gonna be
most impacted which in this case would
be women someone from the other side
sincerely tried to empathize with me
yeah you too Marie have empathized with
me the most
thank you for just understanding me and
then just you know throwing your insight
out there yeah now I really appreciated
how you were able to understand each
different situation and circumstance and
be able to like agree and just agree to
disagree with everything that's being
said I think that this is how real
conversations usually occur and it shows
people that we don't have to avoid a
topic and so thanks for listening and
thanks for sharing and I have to tell
the two of you like I'm sorry and on
behalf of any person who's pro-life who
has ever made you feel criminalized for
having had an abortion and I do not
believe that anyone should face jail
time for having had an abortion like I
understand your circumstances and I
don't even know that feel bad I feel
like I picked on you too yes that was
the odd man out but uh I believe in
women's rights equal pay for equal work
there should be more representation in
government my big thing is that the
fetus is not just a blob of tissue it's
a real person a him or her and maybe I
didn't get that a cross for you to grasp
that on my perspective I hope that it
didn't come across that we are not in
pathetic cuz I know for sure I was
really trying to listen to you and
trying to find a commonality I was
actually like oh interesting okay you
think this and what and why like I think
I think those things are super valuable
too
not have the same perspective but still
be able to find spaces to a line because
that's where the real work is not us all
agreeing but still there are some basic
things we want for humans and women and
so if that's true then we all have to do
some sort of work in some sort of
bending in places to make that be true
[Music]
everybody thank you for watching another
episode of middle ground my name is Erin
and this is Dan and we are both jubilee
directors so you've directed a lot on
middle ground what is something that
you've learned having done all that I
think the biggest thing for my own self
growth is it's made me aware of where my
ignorance is like this has forced me to
really sit down and hear opinions that I
have shut out more often than not and
it's made me have to confront that and
grow from that and be more open yeah I
think once you hear it come from another
human being you have to see the human
being coming with that opinion yeah well
if you guys have any thoughts on what
you've learned for middle ground please
comment below if you like this be sure
to follow us on Instagram that's we're
going to find out a lot more of what's
coming up next in our videos as well as
behind the scenes stuff with us and we'd
love to get to know you there so see you
then